a draw and um i'm thinking of repeating
the position with the petrol this one
this one is
so
i would never want to give up a pawn
next to my king with check
i mean this is incredible can you really
do this if there's no wind for white
right now it's a miracle because black's
king is so open
i can't see it though no i mean you just
assume that the black king is going to
get checkmated because you've got two
heavy pieces around the black king but
yeah the knight does such a good job
he's just stopping that important check
and black is threatening a draw here
yeah a perpetual so
and we're going to see it happen white
is threatening checkmate if white's
queen goes up to the top rank the black
king is trapped but the white king is
helpless and can't defend from these
checks for black queen and knight just
in time to save the draw and we're going
to see the position repeat itself oh
miraculous save at the end there from
amazon drama in the first game for eric
hanson and shakarian momodaro but
eventually it is a
draw we follow